i like reading a book where i have the
sense that the author knows everything
they might not be telling me everything
but you have that confidence
that the author really knows everything
this is what i mean about pace i have to
know exactly even though the reader
might not know when when everything
happens so you have the month that it's
happening so i'm getting the weather
right and everything i reckon
i must have got through 15 different
alternative chapters but one
the reasons for which i discarded each
of them were they all gave too much away
i stopped pretending to myself that i
was anything
other than what i was and began to
direct all my energy
into finishing the only work that
mattered to me
i wasn't someone with an enormous amount
in fact i'd say i was someone
with not much self belief at all and yet
in this one thing in my life
i believed that was the one thing in my
life i felt i can tell a story
[Music]
i often get asked by younger readers
what i would advise
if you want to be a writer this is the
way i did it so that's the only advice i
can give
you've got to read as much as you
possibly can because that's the best way
to
recognize good writing and to learn what
makes bad writing and those are
very good things you probably go through
a phase where you imitate your favorite
writers that's perfectly okay that's
another learning process
you resign yourself to writing lots and
lots of rubbish
you just got to write that out for your
system and sooner or later you'll hit
what you know you really
should be doing and what is your genre
and
perseverance you've got to persevere
because it is a it's a
career with a lot of knockbacks but the
rewards are huge
i don't mean in the sense that if that's
what you really want to do
to be able to do it lifelong is the best
thing in the world
very rewarding but it's not a career for
people who are easily discouraged
that's for sure and to their parents um
don't tell them it's unrealistic never
to never say that
because even if they're not published
writing well writing is the passion of
my life
five years this massive material
was generated some of which will never
find its way into the book we'll never
need to be in the books it's
it's just stuff i need to know for my
own pleasure
partly for my own pleasure and partly
because i like reading a book where i
have the sense that the author knows
everything
they might not be telling me everything
but you have that confidence
that the author really knows everything
okay so this is um
to the untrained eye might look like a
pile of waste paper
but um this is ten years work
as you can see i file meticulously and i
know where every single piece of paper
is
i've dragged out a few bits and pieces
so this is the name of everyone in
harry's year and all these little
symbols mean
what house they're in how magical they
are what their parentage is because i
needed this later for the death eaters
and so on and
the various allegiances that would be
set up within the school
i like this this was agent this was 98
and this was me trying to find words
for the dementors so i have all these
latin words written all over the inside
of my diary
i used to cover just about anything with
writing as you can see
this is my application for housing
benefit
in 28 gardeners crescent which is where
i was the first place i lived obviously
when i was in edinburgh
treated with a complete lack of respect
by me
discarded first chapters of book one i
reckon
i must have got through 15 different
alternative chapters but one
the reasons for which i discarded each
of them were they all gave too much away
and in fact if you put all those
discarded first chapters together
almost the whole plot is explained now
this would be agreed this is the grid of
the book that i'm working at the moment
but we don't want to go too close on
this because this gives stuff away
all right but without being like that no
one can read that that far away but tell
us what
each column is so um
this is what i mean about pace i have to
know exactly even though the reader
might not know when
when everything happens so you have the
month that it's happening so i'm getting
the weather right and everything
the chapter title some of them still to
be decided
and oh dear i don't think anybody can
see this is this is
one one strand of the story the kind of
stuff that has to happen in each chapter
and on the back you have more lines for
other subplots so you know what's going
on but as you see what i mean i i have
to fill in some of this as i go because
as i'm writing
it occurs to me how and when things will
have to happen
so this is one year yeah it's one year
in harry's
in harry's life yeah i wouldn't say that
i based any of these women on specific
women that
that i knew but hermione is an
exaggeration of me
so hermione really did come from a very
deep place inside me
i was very insecure and still i'm quite
insecure in a lot of ways but i was a
very insecure
person for longer than i
like to admit
and i think writing about the time
in hermione's life that i write about
growing from childhood into womanhood
literally because when we finish the
book she's
18. i think it brought back to me how
very difficult it is
so much is expected of you as you become
a woman and
often you are asked to sacrifice
parts of you in becoming a girl i would
say
hermione doesn't she doesn't play the
game if you like but do you find the
whole secrecy
issue the need for secrecy a bit
ridiculous
uh no why not no not at all because
i um
but a lot of it comes from me really
yeah definitely i mean
of course one could be cynical and i'm
sure you would be disposed to be so
and say it was a marketing ploy but i
i don't want the kids to know what's
coming
because that's part of the excitement of
the story and
having you know sweated blood to create
all my red herrings and lay all my
clothes
to me it's not this is my this is i was
going to say this is my life it's not my
life
but it is a very important part of my
life yeah we've mentioned teenagers
several times yep
same thing is true with harry potter
what is it about teenagers i don't know
i do do you think it's a rested
development i don't know
i do know that you said that your
teenage years were not that happy for
you
i love stephen king said if you enjoyed
being a teenager there's something
really wrong with you
and that made me that really struck me
here
i mean i i so a happy teenager could not
write a book like this
or like stephen king no no definitely
not
well actually i think the urge to write
often comes from a wish to rearrange
reality the reality you're in so
i've no i've i don't think i've ever met
him but is it easy to make it a fantasy
or to make it a real
village that has rules to me there's
honestly not much dif there's
truly not much difference and they're
very different kinds of book but for me
um what obsesses me morality
mortality that was those two things most
of all absolutely
through everything exactly you do they
run through harry potter completely they
run through this
i probably will never be able to
morality very close friend of mine
i finished the book and the first thing
he said to me was how many people died
he knows me so because he knows you yeah
exactly but no to go back to the
teenager's point you raise
i think that i am fascinated by people
who are on the cusp of adulthood
uh it's such an interesting time of life
i think most of us would say that we
it's a again it's another very formative
period and everyone tries
but you're also very vulnerable and
these characters are vulnerable
and looking for identification
absolutely and but also what is which is
an interesting thing about adolescence
is often much more concerned with the
big issues of life
than the people in middle age like me
who are struggling with the minutia of
everyday life we all get bogged down in
that to an extent
they are concerned with the essence of
life which is relationships and love
one teenage boy asks another in this
book what matters
and the answer is sex and death and then
as an afterthought
music now none of the adult
characters are having that conversation
this is not their word about
yeah they were worried about paying the
bills it is one of the amazing and
wonderful things about literature
as about film and music is it's utterly
subjective
so it's somebody's opinion the point of
it you know that's the point
of course you work you move in that
world if you expect to just stand under
a shower of perpetual praise there's
something wrong with you exactly
that you know you will you will get
criticism i knew that going in and
the funny thing is i'm not a
particularly um
i was never a very confident person in
their areas in my life in which i'm very
thin
skinned but not in this area in this
area
i i think it's right and proper i should
be criticized and
that's that's and can you learn from it
yeah sometimes
absolutely it depends i mean i there
have been reviews that have
i thought yeah that's that's fair
comment and i need to take that on board
oh yeah
yeah of course failure meant a stripping
away
of the inessential i stopped pretending
to myself that i was anything
other than what i was and began to
direct all my energy
into finishing the only work that
mattered to me
had i really succeeded at anything else
i might never have found the
determination
to succeed in the one arena where i
believed i truly belonged
i was set free because my greatest fear
had been realized
and i was still alive and i still had a
daughter whom i adored
and i had an old typewriter and a big
idea
and so rock bottom became the solid
foundation
on which i rebuilt my life
you might never fail on the scale i did
but some failure in life is inevitable
it is impossible to live without failing
at something
unless you live so cautiously that you
might as well not have lived at all
in which case you fail by default
you